[Musique]
au havre le commandant croisille a fait
au président rené coty les honneurs du
france 97 ans après la mise en service
du paquebot du même nom avec l'ancien
président de la république 400 invités
participaient à la première traverser la
manche avant l'atlantique
une répétition générale en quelque sorte
pour le commandant croisille et ses
hommes est l'occasion de saluer au
passage le liberté pour les 400 invités
ce devait être l'occasion de découvrir
les aménagements de la cité flottante
longue de 315 mètres prévus pour
recevoir 2400 passagers le fumoir des
premières places par exemple qui occupe
toute la largeur du navire soit 32 mais
les cuisines dont il suffit de préciser
qu'elles sont à la mesure de ce futur
balas de l'atlantique
sous ce dôme étoilé qui la domine de 5
mètres cinquante de haut la salle à
manger
[Musique]
la salle de spectacle la plus grande qui
ait jamais été construite sur un navire
et qui possède une capacité de 664 place
[Musique]
tel est le luxe qassam town où il ne
faisait que le courte escale le france a
offert aux personnalités du corps
britanniques et notamment à son ornière
féminin une prochaine croisière aux
canaries permettra d'apprécier un peu
plus ses qualités et ce sera enfin
ouverte la route de new york bonne
chance donc aux france
[Musique]